the 2011 alumni medal for distinguished
service is presented to lisa phillips
davis 1976 Barnard College Lauren was
actually cleaning and I cuz I know for a
lot of people very transformative there
was a French major and I ultimately
became a French translation major and I
did spend a semester over in breed hall
I was here born in on scholarship so I
hadn't really done a lot of traveling
and that was really you know is really
just amazing for me work study was part
of it so my work was in the admissions
office and in a lot of ways that really
became a second home for me it was a
great memories of working there Dorothy
den Berg who later became Dean do you
know the college was working in
admissions then fact then tours were not
what they are in Albert was a huge group
you could take one family if it were to
family should almost apologize for them
that they were having a shared tour and
I felt really good because I knew that I
was represented born and well there was
a long island club that was kind of
teetering I became involved in it and
kind of started organizing a lot of
things and eventually became president
of the club I had junk children at the
time so it was really quite a great
escape into kind of thinking if you had
professor come we really did grow the
club while i was there i still remember
the first meeting where people there
were some people who were literally
almost in tears that they were so
excited that borna was reaching out to
people kind of where they were i think
if i reflect on all the things that i
did the one that really has the most
meeting is being present Alumni
Association I got to work with the
trustees and be a trustee for four years
which was another you know really seeing
border from another side but I think
that we really started to do a lot of
really you know good work that's been
carried forward as much as I love bar
nerd having been the parent of a bar
nerd student has just raised the college
to a whole nother level for me having
watched her experience lisa phillips
davis barnard college
everybody in like damn it just comes did
you hear the forehead really when they
called your name for the middle so it
was just it was a really really great
and really special day it's a wonderful
honor and I'm really thrilled to be able
to represent for it in that way
you